[Music]
sorry out
let's go do some recruiting what is this
place
so headquarters of the Justice Society
of America
[Music]
what is all of this each of the JSA
members had abilities powers tools like
your cosmic staff and they used them to
protect the world against people like
icicle who's that Wildcat his real name
was Ted grant Power Man the flash dr.
fate
there were my friends
my family really
is this thing real court these guys I
mean they were the best in the world but
still with years of experience they
couldn't defeat the injustice society do
you understand that this stuff shouldn't
be sitting here collecting dust it
should be in the hands of possible
heroes don't touch the Thunderbolt
that's the most dangerous thing in here
a pink pin Hey will you just listen to
me for once
everything in this room is dangerous all
right this life is
let's go
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Justice Society video
they just teased a whole bunch of new
characters coming to the show including
Green Lantern new version of the flash
with Jay Garrick's helmet they're in a
new version of dr. faith so we'll break
it all down if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos will do a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know which new
character you want them to introduce on
the show so I'll explain what's going on
in these scenes where they're headed
with this then I'll explain the powers
that each of these items in the armors
grant just starting at the beginning
Luke Wilson's character stripes as he's
known now and his upgraded mech suit is
giving star girl a short history and
tutorial on the Justice Society
she's star man's secret daughter which
is why she's able to wield the cosmic
staff then you get a better look at all
the weapons the armor the magical items
from the final roster of the Justice
Society some of them were confirmed dead
in that first episode I did a video for
their final battle with icicles in
Justice Society so I'll link that video
at the end of this but in order of
appearance she snags Wildcats costume
our man's armor and power our weapon in
the comics he took pills but they might
just change that and connect his
power-ups to the hourglass that he wears
around his neck she snags Alan Scott's
Green Lantern battery
she doesn't take hoody the owl but she
does take dr. Midnight's armor and the
owl is connected to dr. midnight so the
owl will probably just follow whoever
gets the armor she takes Johnny Thunders
Thunderbolt I'll explain how that works
in a second - she also sees dr. fates
helmet of fate is in the hall in Jay
Garrick's flash helmet implying that
they're either retired or they died in
that final battle or they're hiding out
somewhere we did see Jay Garrick's
helmet in the rubble of that big final
battle with the in Justice Society in
episode 1 so in supply that he died but
we're not quite sure what happened to
Alan Scott it's implied that he's dead
it's also implied that the last doctor
fate died too but they could be hiding
out somewhere in town so all these
scenes are just letting us know the new
versions of the characters are going to
debut unless some of the classic ones we
didn't witness die on screen come back
like a new version of Green Lantern I'll
explain how that works in a second -
because Alan Scott did have children in
the comics some of you probably know who
they are or a new version of the flash
although that's a bigger question mark
because technically Jay Garrick doesn't
have children in the comics so I'll talk
about the flash during this
- then once the new version of the
Justice Society team forms let's start
using the Hall of Justice again as their
home base unless they blow this up at
some point - but explaining how all
these most powerful weapons magical
items and armors work so Alan Scott's
Green Lantern battery in his Green
Lantern ring came to him very
differently from the modern-day Hal
Jordan Green Lantern but he's still a
member of the Green Lantern Corps his
Green Lantern battery was made from a
fallen piece of meteor rock that came
from the planet OA the home of the Green
Lantern Corps and the battery just acts
like a portable version of the larger
Green Lantern battery on OA where Hal
Jordan and the other Green Lantern Corps
charged their rings the battery itself
was sentient and it instructed Alan
Scott how to forge his own Green Lantern
ring so his ring didn't come to him from
someone else the way that Hal Jordan got
his ring from a band sir for the most
part Alan Scott's Green Lantern
abilities wear the exact same as any of
the other Green Lantern's you've read in
the comics like how Jordan John Stuart
but in the comics Alan Scott had twin
children Jade a girl and obsidian a boy
if Alan Scott really is dead on the show
as they're kind of implying here but not
confirming my assumption would be that
they introduced his children and they
take the mantle their comic book powers
work a little bit differently though
Jade and her brother were both separated
at birth and given to foster care
because their mother was a split
personality superhero and they feared
that they would be killed and that kind
of goes with the theme of the show but
Jade was actually born with Green
Lantern powers biologically the same
powers that Hal Jordan the other Green
Lantern Corps need their rings for so
she can fly she can create constructs
without the need of a ring you may
remember that they actually did a
version of obsidian on legends of
tomorrow is Justice Society he was
played by Lance Henriksen but it was a
different version of the character and
it was a much older version of the
character in present-day as for a doctor
fate everyone pretty much knows how the
helmet of fate works anyone who wears
the helmet becomes the next Doctor fate
because the spirit of Naboo pretty much
takes over their body if they're not
powerful enough to resist him the helmet
is kind of like a contract that you make
with his spirit or a prison depending on
how you look at it you gain cosmic level
magic power in exchange for never being
able to take the helmet off like you're
dr. fate for the rest of your life or
until you die or someone else takes the
burden
you the spirit of Naboo is super
powerful but is effectively trapped
inside the helmet and it wants out so it
needs someone to become his avatar wear
the helmet so that he can act in the
living world they did a version of dr.
fate on Smallville way back in the day
there's also a new version of dr. fate
that they're supposed to be doing during
the Black Adam movie because they're
doing a version of the Justice Society
during that but that's a little bit
different than I think what they're
doing on the star girl TV show they also
use dr. fate a lot during Young Justice
but we'll see who winds up putting the
helmet on in present-day you don't need
to have any magical abilities to wear
the helmet of fate even the Wally West
flash wore the helmet of fate briefly
during Young Justice because once you
put it on you basically become the
avatar of Naboo fused with his God level
powers also fun fact the original Naboo
when he was still alive was actually the
son of Vandal Savage who was also a
member of the in Justice Society in the
comics so maybe they can use a new
version of Vandal Savage on star girl in
the future if they kill off some of
these in Justice Society members they
haven't really explained how this
version of the flash got his powers Jay
Garrick as you can see it's not John
Wesley's ships Jay Garrick but if
they're going with the original Golden
Age origin he actually got his speed in
a funny way he was inhaling hard water
vapors make all the memes you want those
supposedly activated his meta-gene and
that's how he got his speed but that's
the Golden Age origin once they came up
with the concept of the Speed Force
during the modern age of comics they
sort of retcon that and now Jay Garrick
got his speed from the Speed Force so
we'll see how they try to explain that
on the TV show because Jay Garrick
didn't have any children so I don't know
if somebody's gonna be taking his helmet
or just becoming a new version of the
flash there are a number of candidates
they could do a version of Wally West
they could do a version of Liberty Bell
they could do a version of Jesse quick
there been a number of female speedsters
and other speedsters on the Justice
Society in the comics I think they're
trying to do different versions of the
flash on all the different TV shows so
I'm expecting a slightly different
character that we haven't seen before a
different member of the flash family the
whole thing with Johnny Thunders
Thunderbolt penned the pink pens they
kind of make fun of during the episode
here is that it contains the genie known
as Thunderbolt that's why it's called
the Thunderbolt it's the most dangerous
thing in here the genie has super
powerful magic reality warping abilities
it can give up big energy blasts
visibility it has powers of flight so
sort of a catch-all in terms of what
they can do with it on screen
we'll see who they wind up giving the
pen to wild cat and dr. midnight don't
really have any natural powers wild cat
is just a heavyweight boxing champ of
the world and a badass fighter who knew
how to take a beating and dr. midnight
was just a scientist who built special
goggles that gave him really good night
vision annie was really good at building
explosives
they've already introduced some of the
new versions of the Justice Society
characters you actually saw them during
crisis on Infinite Earths this them in
this roster here so for instance like we
don't see a version of the new Green
Lantern here they might debut that
person either at the end of the season
or in season two just because I don't
think they want to load up on too many
characters in season one but let me know
in the comments what do you want them to
do with the new version of Green Lantern
on the show and what do you want them to
do with the new version of the flash
that they introduced on the show what'll
happen is I'll keep doing videos for
like the really big Justice Society
stuff and they're really big comic book
characters that they introduce so leave
all your big questions and your video
requests for the show and the comments
below
everyone click here to re-watch that
huge opening scene battle between the
Justice Society and the injustice
society and click here for my brand new
one division Marvel trailer video thank
you so much for watching everyone stays
safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you